with no announced hardware additions to
the PlayStation lineup and the looming
release of Microsoft's project Scorpio
console it stands to reason that now
more than ever Sony's e3 press
conference will focus on software first
party exclusives third party games and
titles we may not have seen much of
since their last time in the limelight
perhaps chief among these is the God of
War reboot revealed at last year's Sony
presser considering we saw gameplay all
those months ago it wouldn't surprise us
to see more at e3 2017 we're also
expecting to see something about the
Last of Us - following its reveal at
this year's PlayStation experience it's
unclear if it'll be another teaser
trailer or actual gameplay but it seems
highly unlikely that Sony would avoid
showing the anticipated sequel in some
way and while we're on the topic of
Naughty Dog games uncharted the Lost
legacy releases this August so it won't
be surprised at all to see Sony share
more about this standalone game next
week I thought you were professional no
you should relax
live longer insomniacs open world
spider-man is also likely to make an
appearance it slated to release later
this year and with the same creative
director as a bombastic sunset overdrive
we're expecting to see some frenetic
gameplay on Sony's stage then comes a
handful of title we're not as clear on
Kojima's enigmatic death stranding Ben
Studios survival focus days gone the
platforming sequel Mac 2 and Gran
Turismo sport to name a few but although
they're not confirmed don't count them
out completely when Sony takes the stage
next week in Los Angeles keep in mind
this isn't everything that could show up
at the juggernauts press conference next
week for more on what we want to see at
this year's sony pressor we asked a few
of our editors to outline their hopes
for ìiî 2017 announcements as a fan of
Sony I think that the most important
thing for me to see right now is to see
that Sony isn't becoming complacent they
had an amazing e3 with the e3 of dreams
as it's known with the Shenmue
announcement and the Final Fantasy 7
remake I think they need to dedicate
some of their press conference to
showing that those weren't just kind of
like flights of fancy and that those are
actually becoming substantial products
and that we can see so one thing is they
need to show off those games and we've
all seen the videos of people having
meltdowns the moment the 10.7 remake was
announced and so I can only imagine what
would happen if they actually showed off
a substantial amount of combat and maybe
go deeper into the game and show of
different areas that we haven't seen
before Sony's job is pretty simple focus
on the games which is what they've been
doing for the last couple years
especially if you look at their pressors
the press conferences the last two years
have been very gameplay heavy with
minimal setup from their presenters it's
been two years since Sony's e3 of dreams
when we had Shenmue 3 Final Fantasy 7
remake and The Last Guardian and I think
for them to win III this year they need
to have another press conference that
was like that one that was really like
having these big names that game is so
excited like all in one place they also
need to show their continued commitment
to VR because they are a huge stake in
that VR market right now but I want to
see more meaningful VR experiences so
obviously have all the demos and things
that launched with PlayStation VR but
they aren't really they're not meaty
enough in my opinion
I mean Resident Evil 7 was a glimpse of
what VR is capable of in if in a
full-scale game I really want to see
Sony kind of push that even further it's
not going to be very hard for Sony to
win III if they just do a few important
things that is one focus on games that
are going to be on PlayStation 4 and
PlayStation 4 Pro and not really worry
so much about PlayStation VR
they don't really need to do a whole lot
more than show people that hey we've got
more great games coming for the system
that you already love the Y 7 is going
to win this year it's going to be all
about the games and I think the biggest
one that I'm excited for is finding out
what Sucker Punch has been working on
it's been three years since we've seen
anything from them and they've got to be
working on something that I just I just
can't wait for I love the infamous and
I'm hoping it's a new IP also maybe some
indie stuff I know they always do an
indie showcase so looking forward to
seeing what they're doing with indie
developers and stuff like that then
we're going to see stuff like I'm gonna
put it out there you got dad of war
that's gonna be great
The Last of Us - probably some Uncharted
stuff and then days gone as well I want
to dig in and see what actually days
gone is gonna be see a little bit more
of those hoards and see how they all pan
out to an actual game so for me Sony
always does a pretty good job at every
III I don't think they've had many shows
since like 2005 where they've really
stuffed it up but I think what they can
really do is continue to deliver on
those new IPs personally I'm really
excited to see more of Detroit become
human I'm a huge fan of Quantic Dream
and I think that's got a lot of
potential and one of the other things
I'd really like to see is single player
DLC for horizon zero dawn I feel like
it's really great timing it's not so
late that people have forgotten about
the game but not so early they haven't
finished it yet so I'd be really
surprised if Sony don't jump on that one
at this e3 when this year's e3 is easy
for Sony all they need to do science god
of war for the end of the year last was
- for the end of the year and the nights
that night - has been cancelled so there
you have it what we expect to see and
what we want to see at Sony's e3 2017
press conference we're quickly
approaching the show and news will
undoubtedly release in the days leading
up to it for more on Sony's
announcements and all the stories
emerging from the conference's next week
be sure to visit our GameSpot now app on
iOS and Android we'll see you there
[Music]